- I want a breakfast sandwich right now.
(upbeat dance music)
- Jack in the Box has the best breakfast.
- McDonald's.
- McDonald's all day, every day.
- Everything is nicely layered,
and clearly processed.
- This is like a breakfast sandwich
you get in middle school.
- This croissant is on point.
- That's a good breakfast sandwich.
- Everything's got the right textures,
but the flavor's just not there.
- This one looks like
the eggs are so fake.
- Is this steak sausage?
This sausage is amazing.
- This is too much bread.
I don't appreciate this.
- Oh, I'm lovin' this.
Every bite I take is
better than the last one.
- This one has to be McDonald's.
- That one's McDonald's.
- Mm,mm,mm, mm.
- It smells like alcohol and pancakes.
- Nope, never mind, it's not McDonald's.
- Not McDonald's.
- Uh-uh.
- Good presentation.
- I don't wanna look at the meat.
- There's very little cheese.
- There's no cheese.
- No, that's the worst one yet.
- Yeah.
- This is the worst smelling one by far.
- Yeah, this smells like McDonald's.
- This cheese, it just looks
like Frankenstein cheese.
It looks orange.
- McDonald's is symmetrical.
You can tell McDonald's cuz it's like very
clearly made by machines.
- It's not great.
It's pretty good.
- This tastes like America.
- If this is McDonald's
I'm really disappointed in McDonald's.
- Yeah, this would only
be like if I was free,
and if there wasn't a banana around.
- Oh my gosh.
- They're not skimping on the bread.
That's for sure.
- [man on right] No.
- Why is this sausage so dark?
- Oh my God, squeeze it.
- Yeah, this biscuit feels great.
- It tastes home made.
It tastes like my grandma's biscuits.
- Bread's drowning out the rest of this.
- If they fix their bun to meat ratio
you've got a winner.
- Everything came off clean
except for the cheese left
a little bit of residue.
(laughter)
- This egg looks real real.
- Look like it was made on a griddle.
- Everything has butter in it.
It's amazing.
- This is good.
It's really like the most mild in flavor.
- I don't like the egg,
but it's so easy to just whip it off,
and throw it out the window.
- This has to be McDonald's.
It has to be.
- Overall I choose this one.
(bell ring)
- Jack in the box. (bell ring)
- It's delicious.
- Yeah, Jack in the Box is so good.
- That one (bell ring)
is still my favorite.
- This one (bell ring) was my favorite.
It was so good y'all.
Who's this?
- [Voiceover] Jack in the Box.
- Ahh.
- So that was Jack in the Box.
- I knew it.
I called it from the beginning.
This is like Ryan Gosling,
and this is George Clooney.
This one's just like a little
bit more like sophisticated.
It's a lot better.
- What's this one?
- That's just--
(laughter)
- That's Pee Wee Herman right there.